president biden pressing ahead with his
climate agenda today despite concerns
that will lead to job losses
republicans criticizing the president
after canceling
the keystone xl pipeline and putting
some people out of work
and biden's presidential envoy for
climate john kerry
he's staring more outraged take a look
at what kerry said when he was asked
about the potential
for more job losses in the fossil fuel
industry
unfortunately workers have been fed a
false narrative
no surprise right for the last few years
they've been fed
uh the notion that somehow dealing with
climate
is coming at their expense no it's not
and i think that
workers are going to see that with the
efforts of the biden administration
they're going to have a much better set
of choices and frankly
it will create more jobs than stuck
where we were
uh greg let me start with you i think
there are legitimate concerns about the
changes in the job market but uh today
150 corporate leaders
you know people in the auto industry the
airlines manufacturing even the energy
sector
signed on to the biden effort they said
the u.s needs to
be at the edge of innovation and it can
create what they called
green jobs what do you say oh they're
probably getting some money out of that
so i don't blame them and it's a little
virtue signaling that they all have to
do
look my problem with joe is he doesn't
follow the science he neither does kerry
they keep talking about how the wild
fires are linked to climate change
it used to there were more wildfires i
think five to ten times more
area in the early 1900s than there are
now
and the present wildfires that were what
we're experiencing now are due to forest
management
and in perfect zoning uh that's been
well documented
also uh there are 17 times more homes
in high risk areas for wildfire risk
and flood zones haven't really moved but
people have moved into flood zones and
that creates
a problem i think the point in one of
the bigger points though is that
i just saw schumer declare wants to
declare
climate a national emergency where the
hell has he been we are
in a national emergency the guy just
wants more money
and more power and more control over
people it's like the shutdown
just tickled their thirst for even more
draconian manipulation
it's grotesque this is all a power grab
all right so dana i was interested in
the poll numbers because
it's like 60 percent of americans say
climate change
is a threat to the country but i notice
it's disproportionately among democrats
and independents republicans don't buy
into it
what do you make of that again we've
been rounding around
this mulberry bush before there are many
many republicans and
look matt gates the republican from
florida
he believes that it is uh real and that
has an impact um and that he wants to do
something about it and there are many
republicans say
yes it's happening we can figure out
what to do about it but let's not just
kill all the jobs in the process and
basically take a step backwards from
america's energy independence
i think some of these communications
strategies that they've had from the
white house on these
executive orders have been very tone
deaf they sound like they're presenting
at an aspen ideas festival
and saying that the green new jobs will
be there for you is like
learn to code now if they can put up
let's see those jobs let's see if it
happens but it didn't happen
in eight years from 2009 to 2016.
all right so jesse did you agree with
greg because i know last year we had
terrible year for wildfires drought uh
flooding
uh i mean these things really happen we
all saw it so
isn't it time to act right right
it's time time to act juan we have to
act the only thing we can do is kill
jobs and put solar panels everywhere
i'm with dana juan i mean
how cavalier can you be john kerry's
like oh yeah
those pipe guys yeah they could just
build solar panels right
that's like telling me and the parts
come from china jesse
right right like jesse yeah we're gonna
fire you from your job at fox and
and you can be an actor because you know
you're used to being behind the camera
like i can't act you to train me to act
no one's gonna watch that film
i mean one i'm all for clean energy
clean energy
solar and wind make up five percent of
our energy portfolio
eighty percent of the energy portfolio
is fossil fuels
gas oil and coal and it's been like that
since 1900 okay you can put solar panels
in the southwest where it's sunny
you could do hydro in the northwest and
then you can do
windmills in the plains where it's windy
and flat but that doesn't work
everywhere
let's not just kill jobs for you know
pr okay there's a lot of work to do on
i don't know high-speed internet or
upgrading the electrical grid
why can't we start there
alright so katie final word senator
schumer says this all fits in
with what he sees as a bipartisan issue
infrastructure that they can build more
infrastructure and do it
as a green project what do you think
well you know what's an infrastructure
project the keystone
xl pipeline which the biden
administration just destroyed
so this whole we're going to build
infrastructure thing doesn't really pan
out when they're trying to build a
safe clean way in a pipeline to
transport fossil fuels
this could go i could talk about this
for hours but just quickly i will say
this whole like green energy thing is a
total
farce okay solar panels are not green
windmills are not green do the research
they come over here from china
they're brought over here by fossil
fuels they are built with
uh you know built with minerals that are
mined out of the ground using fossil
fuels it goes on and on and on
uh there's a great documentary there's a
great documentary with more on this
called
not evil just wrong as a counter to al
gore's nonsense
by ann mcelheny and phil and macca lear
i suggest everybody watch it to get a
different perspective on this
you are not a climate denier or science
denier if you have questions about
big government uh getting in bed with
these solar companies and it's just like
cylindra all over again right
in the obama administration where
they're telling people to use
to like leave your high-paying job in
the oil industry for a company that's
going to go bankrupt i don't think so
solyndra all right thank